which is what you said a moment ago
about how James Vaughn is and like
involved in more things that you know
been the normal hero or act or whatever
and we got dog
we always got done welcome welcome to
region
[Music]
what is up reject nation my name is John
Humphrey and with me is Jeb it away
mister Jabby Co am the jab eco a YouTube
channel and today we're gonna we thought
we'd hit you with a little discussion
right how am i doing am i doing okay
you're doing pretty good man
good yeah you are professional I like to
have everything rely on thanks man
yeah really appreciate what else do you
like with me uh well a lot of things but
we will talk about that here today in
the news just came out the Daniel Craig
is going to do the next James Bond movie
actually is the news broke on the which
was shows think about the Colbert you've
just been a late night show yeah this is
a Tonight Show to the tonight's that is
on a special well we should say that we
got there we got there just took two of
us to figure it out but as John would
soon realize they actually hadn't
figured it out it's been a long
afternoon it not happens in you're
relying google for like you know fifteen
years of your life but he flat-out said
it he is going to do the next James Bond
movie kind of explained the incident
that happened when he said he'd rather
slash his wrists I saw I was thinking
about when you said that I'm like I
thought he would rather kill himself and
they got to that pretty quick I've been
quite cagey about I've been doing
interviews all day and people have been
asking me and I think I've been rather
coy but I kind of felt like you know
sort of is going to sort of speak the
truth I should speak the truth to you uh
Daniel Craig will you return as James
Bond yes
thanks so much Daniel Craig everybody
I always wanted to I needed a break we
always want to interview after you've
been respecter who said I'd rather slash
mother in Hmong again I can't believe
you've got that written down it was two
days after I finished shooting the last
movie and I instead of saying something
you know I would style and grace I gave
a really stupid answer I am surprised
that you know if that statement hasn't
hurt him in the least yeah you know and
I'm surprised it hasn't hurt James Bond
and all in the least like that's a
pretty big statement but I guess we're
getting more used to celebrities saying
things yeah what's his name Jim Carrey
was totally against kick-ass hno2 and I
didn't I don't know if that hurt the
film at all I don't think it did the
only other example that comes to mind is
the guy beside the Joker Jared Leto yeah
he was I was spoken against the film
because you know to cut half his [ __ ]
from the movie but yeah and the thing is
like people don't seem to be very
forgiving of him and and it seemed like
people were more I don't know open to
what Daniel Craig said at the time
because I feel like the performance
inspectors when they do with that
because nobody seems like they liked
that movie okay and I feel like that
helps his case almost people like it
he's done a bunch of these this one
wasn't very good like yeah why not let
him leave you know I would call that his
Russell Crowe Academy Award moment
because we also Pro got the Academy
Award for gladiator he was very
unappreciative of what just happened
like if you go back and watch his press
right after winning the award but what I
put on a costume I said my lines what's
the big deal like he just could not give
an ass [ __ ] about the FepA t just for
an academy award something so few people
have done and he just took it for
granted and so I think Daniel Craig hit
that moment where he took it for granted
for a hot second and right after he's
like wow that was dumb I actually
appreciate this because I'm one of the
luckiest people in the world yeah and I
mean watching him on the oceans no an
actor but he did seem very enthused
about the news and there was a tag at
the end where he basically said like you
wanted to go out on a high note
yeah and I can definitely see that
motivation is this the last Bond can you
tell me if you do the one out
it I think is it I just want to go out
on a high note and huh I can't wait
respecter like the Temple of Doom like
with it that but I didn't see the movie
Greg puts it this way Quantum of Solace
is a worse movie but somehow Spectre is
much more disappointing okay is how he
put that and that's kind of the echo I
heard from everybody else's like in
terms of being a competently made motion
picture yeah you know Quantum of Solace
is almost unintelligible like that movie
gave me such a headache and I've heard
that you know Spectre kind of tries to
split the difference
bring in some of the old Bond stuff some
of the suave you know gadgets and you
know humor and things like that also
balancing it with the grittiness that
they've established in the Daniel Craig
series and I heard that that kind of
just resulted in this limp sort of dry
movie that no one seemed very engaged
did you like the one before uh Skyfall
except the Alex kappa i you know the
only Bond movie with Daniel Craig that
I've enjoyed is the first one Casino
Royale I like a fight scene in Quantum
of Solace but overall like I film wasn't
very good thing I don't think there's
that many James good James Bond movies
that have been made in the past 20 years
to be perfectly honest Pierce Brosnan is
my personal favorite bond of the series
and when Daniel Craig first signed up
for it I was like absolutely that's
again like why him like that's the odd
choice and kind of gotten accustomed to
him but I still don't feel like he's
gotten a great Bond movie and so I
understand what he's saying like he'd
like to go out on a high note
he's got that position I would say yeah
like do it dude I was kind of hoping and
rusev elbow was going to take over the
position according to age of Zelda
Daniel Craig screwed up that position
for Donna because by saying to the world
I'd like it just all want to be the
first black bond idris elba field that
you [ __ ] them out of that opportunity
ah like that's a drag yeah because like
the internet blew up about a racist came
out about it and then you know just a
third people suggest either sell before
everything like whenever it comes to
like hey we should cast more black
actors each result was like the first
person anybody anybody throws out but I
feel like bond would be a
very cool roll to see Paul not noticed I
heard that a Gisela is doing the next
verse leave I'll pick so did you go to
play Bruce Lee yeah nice nice got the
matter leave vendor rah yeah I can see
where Daniel Craig is coming from with
this because James Bond comes with a lot
of extra stuff and I've heard that that
part of what makes this role so
demanding is not only are you making a
big blockbuster movie but you have to
shoot a bunch of extra commercials and a
bunch of other product tie-ins and like
the character has to appear in more
places than just your normal role would
so I construe know I can see what is
taxing and demanding about a character
like this but I can also see how you
know with time you would stop and you
would want to come back and you know
really put your stamp on it especially
after the abysmal reception that the
specter got because even Quantum of
Solace can rest on the whole writers
strike thing which is what you said a
moment ago about how James Bond isn't
like involved in more things that you
know been the normal hero or act or
whatever I read when they did I think
golden a high Pierce Brosnan's line the
things we do for frequent flyer miles
the director had to fight for that tooth
and nail just without joke because like
it's a worldwide fill it's always been a
worldwide thing and so you know that
just speaks to what you're talking about
how it's just is everywhere the
marketing and all that stuff I'm curious
about what they're going to make this
story into because it's 25 you know 25th
film and to give that something that's a
little more than another just wrote
diabolical scheme of some kind of minute
I can tie it into the real world brexit
just happened you want that do you want
that I don't wonder we've done this 24
times ya know like I'd like you in
effect on something different I'm not
saying it's going to be deep yeah my
saying has got to be like let's
deconstruct politics yeah but you know
like there's a lot to utilize I feel
like in that especially the way tension
in the world is there now like there's a
lot you can at least utilize for
entertainment value which people aren't
afraid to do Casino Royale came out we
were like cool gray James Bond let's
gets more you know kind of dog fighting
stuff and since then it seems like
they're sort of struggling to figure out
what's next to do
because that was like I said they tried
to bring in classic elements to Spectre
yeah
and that didn't seem like it works so
well either I personally think that they
should just own the style that has been
James Bond for many years the gritty
James one it's like that's not I don't
James Bond wasn't written as a gritty
character as far as I know like he was
written as a classy yet distinguished
gentleman which Daniel Craig what he
brings to it is it is a very different
kind of character and so I'm happy to
see him do it one more time as a good
send-off hopefully but I would love to
see in the installment after that to go
back to what James Bond was before it's
not with the times the thing is like
James Bond is not a character who does
what it's PC today yeah so I don't know
this is a cool news for Daniel Craig I
guess they're like what I take away from
this the most I care is kind of I hope
you can do a great one before you leave
well you definitely feel like that's my
feeling
I do like Daniel Craig a lot though it's
like separate from James Bond actually
appreciate his exacting and and what he
brings to each role that he does I think
that he's actually really really good
yeah I just was reluctant to have him as
bond in the beginning he's grown a
little bit on me but I'm still like that
correct good but do a good one and like
do a good one before you leave going
back to what we said at the beginning
like I can actually completely
understand why he said he would say I'd
what I'd rather cut my wrists and do
this again I fully sympathy of him at
that time because those films are just
not they've been getting kind of you
know well yes he might for a while there
that was kind of all he got to do and it
seems like they've taken at least a
minute they're taking a minute with this
Bond movie and he's gotten a chance to
go do some other things first
they're you know which always reduces
you rejuvenates you right oh yeah II
agree vigor it's your spirit to do it
again makes you forget look the shitty
process you went through but I'm sure
like he probably got hurt doing some of
the action in James Bond is like I think
that this is a tall order yeah comment
below let us know what how do you feel
about this are you excited to see
another Daniel Craig James Bond do you
wish you would step aside let somebody
else feel the shoes let us know what you
think I'm sitting with the actor played
mad eyes movie
Oh brendan gleeson that's a different
direction for James Bond yeah shut that
my god should have a older guy is angry
that's probably what spies really looked
like now I got imagine spider not like
super charming handsome like right
conspicuous people better get the job
done
yeah you got to probably be an
average-looking dude to be a really
great nice yeah
well that's it guys you can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell get notified every time a review or
a video is out shabby tube you can
subscribe to Jabby tube on the internet
i deliberately made it confusing so i
you did my research youtube cop
selection - for the reactions and
reviews and then twitter instagram is at
jebbie Kawai awesome and comment below
when who would you James Bond and until
next time the name is James Bond good
night we shift up with not it